voici un geste qui ne sera bientôt plus
possible dans un logement neuf à Laval
la ville se dirige vers une sortie du
gaz naturel présentement on prépare un
règlement pour empêcher que les
nouvelles constructions résidentielles
fassent le choix du gaz naturel énergie
reconnaitre environ 150 nouveaux clients
par année à la balle une clientèle qui
serait donc perdue et l'entreprise met
en garde la ville de bien distinguer les
besoins entre une petite maison et un
plus grand ensemble la grande tour elle
doit chauffer des espaces communs des
garages et tout ça ça tire plus de jus
donc ça nécessite d'autres alternatives
des alternatives comme la bille énergie
70% d'électricité 30% de gaz
Hydro-Québec voit aussi d'un mauvais œil
le bannissement de cette option si on y
va tout à l'électrique dans le chauffage
des bâtiments mais on risque de
compromettre d'autres projets
d'électrification
l'électricité n'est pas illimitée et
même après le récent épisode de vergla
Laval n'envisage pas d'exception elle
pense plutôt à la prochaine étape la
conversion des appareils existants les
gens qui chauffent au mazout et des
subventions pour convertir vers
l'électricité donc c'est peut-être une
avenue qu'on vouloir envisager dans une
deuxième étape également pour le gaz
naturel Laval dit vouloir être en avant
de la parade et sa grande voisine
Montréal qui prépare un règlement à ce
sujet la regarde avec intérêt
commencer déjà c'est que il faut
s'éloigner le plus possible des énergies
fossiles et même quand on parle de gaz
naturel renouvelables il faut vraiment
s'assurer d'en faire bon usage au bon
endroit les deux villes sont sur la même
longueur d'onde ce GNR qui représente 1%
du volume distribué par énergie devrait
alimenter les plus grands consommateurs
le gaz naturel renouvelable dont nous
parle souvent mais pour aller vers ces
industries qui en ont absolument besoin
mais le résidentiel on en a pas besoin
de gaz naturel on dit allons 100%
électrique l'Association de la
construction du Québec salue la démarche
de Laval mais s'inquiète d'un éventuel
coup à la hausse des futurs logements ou
tout électrique ici Mathieu pros
Radio-Canada Montréal